[Applause]
after a closely fought election
adamabado has been re-elected
as the gambia's president
he defeated five other candidates to win
a second five-year term
and uh having received 450
519 votes in the election the chairman
of the independent electoral commission
ali mahmoud
declares mr adama barrow is duly elected
to serve as president of the republic of
the gambia
banjo a constituency he so convincingly
won in this election
erupted in celebrations
[Applause]
basking in his victory barrow addressed
supporters at the independence square
having been the lucky person
to be chosen
by you
i
and every sincerely of you
that i will do all i can
and utilize every resource at my
disposal to make the gambia a better
place for us all
very few people predicted the margin of
borrow's victory will be this why
the election was tight and bitterly
fought mr barrow's role will now include
healing a divided nation not only
because of this election but also after
yaya jamie's 22-year brutal rule
baro's opponents have refused to accept
the result we are concerned
that there has been
an inordinate delay
in the announcement of the results
two
a number of issues
have been raised by our agents and
representatives at the polling stations
centers
and at the iec headquarters as a result
the representatives of the
aforementioned candidates
at the iec headquarters refused to
endorse
some of the results
independent observers say the vote was
largely free and fair
the country's election commission has
also defended the election process as
credible and fair it is within their
rights
to confirm or not to confirm decide or
not to con or not to sign despite them
being present and then they were part of
the review process
rival candidates have 10 days to
challenge baro's victory and seem
certain that the fight will now move to
the courts muhammad idris al-jazeera
banjo the gambia